[Music]
billions of years from now the sun will
become a red giant
and then
it will slowly die
that's right it's the end of the solar
system and this is your survival guide
what will happen when earth becomes too
toasty to sustain life
where else in the solar system could
human civilization live
and what would the sun be like in its
final days
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you survived the end of the
solar system
for around four and a half billion years
our sun has been the bright center of
our solar system
it's fueled by the nuclear fusion in its
core and it burns through 661
million tons of hydrogen
every second
during its stellar lifespan the sun has
burned through about half of its fuel
source
that means our sun has another 5 billion
years left in it
as the sun uses up its hydrogen through
nuclear fusion it becomes more saturated
with helium and that makes it spit out
even more energy
every billion years that it burns
hydrogen our sun gets about 10 percent
brighter
eventually all that energy will push out
the sun's outer layers and our star will
swell in size
then we'll have a red giant at the
center of our solar system
hey anything's possible
especially on this channel but what if
you could explore the future of our
world today at the museum of the future
in dubai you can experience scientific
breakthroughs and discoveries in
intricate detail for a vacation you'll
never forget
whether you want to learn about
innovations in health transportation or
space travel this institution brings
together the brightest minds on the
planet and their ideas into interactive
exhibits made for the entire family to
enjoy
lose yourself in the vault of life or a
tropical rainforest simulator or learn
what lies ahead for us beyond our planet
on the orbital space station hope
with five levels and more than 50
exhibits the museum of the future is the
perfect way to experience our road ahead
in a hopeful and engaging experience
plan your next trip with us here in the
future
these next few decades could look bright
for us but beyond that
well
things get tricky
let's fast forward to around one and a
half billion years from now
sorry to say but things won't be looking
too good for life on earth
the sun's increased brightness will set
off intense global warming
our planet will become so hot that our
oceans will start to boil
the increasing heat and radiation of our
sun will shift the habitable zone of our
solar system
and now the area where liquid water
could exist will move out toward mars
yeah mars will now become habitable
and it could be humanity's first
destination for settlement
but to create a breathable atmosphere
we'd still have to terraform the red
planet
at this point mars could remain
habitable for as long as 5 billion years
that'll give us plenty of time to make
our next move
but in about
and a half billion years
our solar system will have a giant
problem a red giant problem of course
our star will run out of its hydrogen
fuel and start burning helium instead
the sun will expand completely
vaporizing mercury
the atmosphere of venus will burn up
eventually the expanding sun will
swallow venus whole
and our earth
well it will get reduced to a dense hot
iron core
our new home on mars won't be habitable
anymore either
humanity's best hope would be to hop
over to europa
jupiter's fourth largest moon
its thick layer of ice will melt from
the sun's increased heat
europa could become a wonderful water
world
jupiter's moon could be our home for a
few hundred million years
that's when the sun will reach its
maximum size as a red giant
it will shine about 3 000 times brighter
than it does today
and its surface could extend well beyond
earth's orbit
eight billion years from now the sun
could make life intolerable as far as
pluto our best hope at that point would
be to find a home on a distant dwarf
planet in the kuiper belt
the temperatures there could be similar
to what we were used to on earth
life on earth would be a thing of the
very very distant past for this
generation of humans
two billion years after that our sun's
fuel reserves will completely dry up
the sun will become unstable and will
start to pulse
this will cause it to shrug off its
outermost layers
the sun will change from a red giant to
a white dwarf this means it will shrink
until it becomes the size of earth today
it will blast off massive amounts of
x-ray radiation but
less heat
so the habitable zone will dramatically
shift once again
it could go from the kuiper belt to
about where mercury used to be
for human civilization to continue we'd
have to move on to another star's
habitable exoplanet
our white dwarf star would radiate for
quadrillions of years so
moving back to its new habitable zone
wouldn't be a good idea
when our former sun used up the last of
its energy it will no longer be able to
shine or radiate heat
but it will still have mass and
gravitational pull
it may become a black dwarf
scientists have yet to find any such
stars as
they would have to be much older than
our 14 billion year old universe
alright so you've made it to the end of
the solar system
i'm sure it wasn't easy to say goodbye
to the sun but
hey
at least it's not exploding tomorrow
that's a story
for another what if
[Music]